bonsoir jacques alors peut-être le bout
du tunnel dans ces négociations du but
du break site avec toutes ces
tergiversations
jacques que se passe-t-il dans ces
négociations de la dernière heure voire
de la dernière minute
c'est très simple nous sommes en train
de vivre un grand classique c'est comme
dans un match du tournoi des six nations
on est en train de jouer les arrêts dieu
parce qu'il faut savoir que légalement
en réalité l'accord aurait déjà dû être
signé d'ici dimanche dernier au soir est
donc là on est effectivement dans ce
qu'on appelle les arrêts de jeu bon
après il faut comprendre que là chacun
prétend qu'il va être avantagés dans un
cas du no deal mais que si on regarde
les choses et c'est plutôt la grande
bretagne qui sortirait avantagés dans
cette situation en tous les cas les
dirigeants britanniques le pense le
savent et c'est pour ça j'ai une
certaine manière qu'ils sont qui ne sont
pas prêts aujourd'hui à faire des
concessions mais pourtant jacques heures
on cesse de dire que le royaume uni a
beaucoup à perdre si on regarde les
chiffres c'est à dire que si on regarde
les flux d'importation et d'exportation
les exportations britanniques les
importations de des britanniques depuis
d autres pays eh bien on voit que en
fait ce sont les pays de l'union
européenne qui sont de gros exportateurs
nets vers le royaume-uni la france les
pays-bas l'allemagne
évidemment et on sait très bien que dans
ce genre de situation c'est le pays qui
est exportateur qui a le plus à perdre
d'un arrêt du commerce cela boris
johnson le sait et il en joue
est ce que ça veut dire que la grande
bretagne n'aurait donc pas grand chose à
perdre d'un odile alors les coûts sont
quand même un petit peu plus compliqué
que ça parce que là on a parlé
la balance commerciale pour les bleus il
ya aussi évidemment les services et en
ce qui concerne les services
là pour le coup c'est la grande bretagne
qui est exportatrice nette de service
les autres pays étant plutôt
importateurs et simplement ce que ça
veut dire c'est que dans le cas d'un
odile tout le monde aurait un petit peu
à souffrir de cette situation
mais ce ne serait pas les mêmes qui
souffrirait si vous voulez dans l'union
européenne ça ferait essentiellement les
producteurs de biens industriels les
usines faisant le secteur de la
transformation des biens agricoles
donc là ces gens auraient des pertes
nettes et puis par contre pour les
britanniques
ce serait plutôt le secteur des services
est essentiellement le secteur bancaire
alors là il faut se dire immédiatement
deux choses c'est que en ce qui concerne
les exportations de biens et bien ce
serait l'allemagne qui perdrait le plus
l'allemagne exporte quand même vers le
royaume uni
l'équivalent de deux points et demi de
son pipe c'est pas du tout négligeable
c'est quelque chose qui pèse lourd dans
la balance allemande
inversement on sait que les britanniques
c'est le rôle de la cité compte beaucoup
sur leurs banques mais et ça c'est
peut-être un point que l'on a oublié de
regarder et il y a aussi beaucoup de
banques européennes qui se sont
installés à londres parce que londres
est un marché financier beaucoup plus
important que nous les barriques ne
l'ait francfort et ce sont elles qui en
réalité auraient le plus à perdre
injac anodine ça veut dire que ce serait
alors mutuellement avantageux alors oui
anodine seraient mutuellement
désavantageux mais il faut là aussi
rappeler c'est que que ce soit le
royaume uni ou les pays de l'union
européenne
tous ces pays sont des signataires de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce ont
signé la charte de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce
donc on se pose immédiatement la
question des mais après tout puisqu'il y
à cette charte puisque cette charte en
fait
d'une certaine manière organise déjà les
échanges pourquoi est-ce qu'on se fait
peur avec sono digne pas le problème qui
est sous jacent mais qu'il faut bien
avoir à l'esprit c'est que l'union
européenne était parti dans l'idée de
faire payer aux britanniques
le vote du break 6 essais ça en réalité
qui a beaucoup on veut ni mais
l'ensemble des relations commerciales
donc ça veut dire que le divorce risque
donc de mal se passer alors ah oui dites
vous qu on était parti sur de très
mauvaises bases
il faut se rappeler que en 2016 qu après
le vote du brics et après le référendum
au royaume uni michel barnier par
exemple avait dit qu'il voulait faire
payer aux britanniques
cette décision alors ce qu'on a vu c'est
que depuis 2007
et bien la négociation n'a pas été un
long fleuve tranquille
ainsi je puis faire cette petite
métaphore cinématographique mais et ça
c'est un point important à partir du
moment où boris johnson est arrivé on
s'est mis à négocier plus sérieusement
et les pays européens ont plus ou moins
renoncé à cette idée de faire payer le
royaume uni de ce point de vue là il y
avait trois points qui étaient
absolument cruciaux sur deux de ces
points que ce soit par exemple sur les
règles de concurrence
où que ce soit sur la manière dont on
règlera des conflits à venir dans le
commerce
eh bien on a trouvé un accord et
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus que le
problème de la pêche
elle quitte bloc l'accord jacques est ce
que cette question de la pêche et donc
six centrales que cela alors c'est ça
qui est extrêmement intéressant c'est
que la pêche ne pèse pas très lourd
quand on regarde les dizaines de
milliards d'euros ou 2 livres
c'est à peu près la même chose
maintenant du commerce
vous savez les pays européens pêche pour
environ 650 milles
d'euros dans les eaux britanniques et
inversement gdri tanner pêche pour à peu
près 120 millions d'euros dans les eaux
des pays de l'union européenne bon c'est
pas des sommes énormes mais il ya deux
problèmes qui sont tout à fait important
un premier c'est un problème social et
j'aiderai même politique dans les pays
de l'union européenne essentiellement en
france aux pays bas un petit peu aussi
en espagne et bien la question de la
survie d'un secteur de la pêche est une
question sociale extrêmement délicate et
on voit très bien qu'il pourrait y avoir
des démobilisations important ça c'est
un premier point inversement on a
toujours tendance à oublier le grand
passé navale de la grande bretagne et on
a tendance à oublier tout l'aspect
symbolique que prend pour les
britanniques
le fait de retrouver le contrôle de
leurs eaux territoriales est ce qu'on
appelle aussi de leur zone exclusive
donc il va falloir d'une certaine
manière que l'on trouve un compromis
entre ces deux questions mais tout en
sachant quand même que le poids général
des problèmes de la pêche ne pèse pas
lourd au regard du commerce entre
l'union européenne et la grande bretagne
mais alors qu'est ce qui va se passer
avec le pronostic
alors oui il ya maintenant plusieurs
possibilités alors la première
possibilité c'est effectivement
contenait un accord d'ici ce soir bon
voilà on aura on aura joué les arrêts de
jeu avec toujours ce risque que l'un des
deux adversaires marquent l'essai dans
les 30 dernières secondes du match à un
grand classique pour tout amateur de
rugby
on a aussi une autre possibilité on n'a
pas d'accord mais on a un accord pour
constater le désaccord et pour continuer
à négocier
ce qui veut dire que de fait on est bien
dans un odile mai
on ne touche arrière où on touche à un
minimum de choses et on va continuer à
discuter
ça peut être une solution et cette
solution d'une certaine manière serait
un démenti cinglant à tous les gens qui
disent mais bruno dive ça serait une
catastrophe ça serait une catastrophe
pour la grande bretagne
il ne pourrait plus obtenir de salade de
brocoli bref il ya toute une série de
délire là dessus et puis il ya une
troisième solution était peut-être une
solution qui est envisagé aujourd'hui
par jerrycan hic c'est que le royaume
uni passe des négociations pays par pays
et de ce point de vue là il faut savoir
que l'allemagne commence à tendre un
petit l'oreille dans cette direction je
vous le rappelle le l'excédent
commercial de l'allemagne vis-à-vis du
royaume-uni est énorme
les exportations allemandes vers le
royaume uni sont tout à fait
considérable et l'allemagne a beaucoup à
perdre d'une situation où il n'y aurait
aucun accord on a compris jacques c'est
donc le money-time merci pour cette
analyse prospective
on n'a visiblement pas encore fini avec
avec le break site un feuilleton sans
fin à la semaine prochaine jacques merci
et bon noël